hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer a question
from one of my four meters GT who's
asking about online advertising if I use
it and how I use it so I do a little bit
of online advertising I used to do more
when we had products to sell but now the
only product that I really sells a
service that I work with some
corporations on how to target
entrepreneurs so what I love about
advertising is you can target specific
community so I like using Facebook as a
medium for advertising here you can say
I want to target anybody who works at a
specific company and has who has
specific job titles or interests so for
example if I was selling something to
car manufacturers and I wanted to break
into the car manufacturer industry I
could say I want to target anybody who
works at Toyota or GM or Ford and has a
marketing title or has a marketing
interest and then your ad would only
show up to people who have those
specific interests so it's a great way
to be able to target specific people at
specific companies to be able to sell
your product or service so it's really
niching out who you're selling to wear a
lot of other advertising programs your
kind of hitting mass market and it's
hard to be able to pinpoint who you're
going to be selling to so I really like
Facebook advertising for that reason you
can really get specific on who you're
selling to so it's figuring out what are
your products or services who is your
ideal target client what kind of
demographics they might represent male
female what kind of age range location
and then you can set up your ads to be
able to sell own to those people so you
may only be selling to a thousand people
or 500 people on your list but you know
that they're super targeted people and
they'll see your message over and over
and over again and really increases your
ability to convert those guys will do
some work on Adwords just testing
different messaging it's a great way to
get quick reaction to see what messages
are working better than others so you
can run split test with different
marketing headlines and see when which
one gets a better reaction
most of our advertising that we do now
is on facebook so I hope that helps if
you do have a product or service a cell
you can do a lot more with with the
advertising options I would definitely
make sure you include tracking so if
you're using AdWords you could track all
the way to the sale and and make sure
you can tell you know which keywords are
generating what what product sales
numbers it's a fantastic way to be able
to grow your business quickly and
directly measure the the ROI just make
sure you're always testing the different
messages that you use split testing them
trying to always beat the first one
that's coming up in your overall results
and try to keep beating that beating
that pdanet so I hope that helps I'd
love to hear what you guys are doing if
you want to leave a comment under the
video I also always appreciate any
thumbs ups you want to give to any of
these videos so hopefully hear from you
down below and stay tuned for the next
episode
you
you